let's just wing it what you got there I
have a copy of um your book dude and
look at
this never in my life right and I'm like
I was
born it's funny that like when I first
saw it when I came in I opened it and
where did it land it opened on your page
it's like dead center I'm like dead
center it's amazing and this photo of me
depicts exactly where I was at that time
like when you look at when I look at
myself then I know exactly where my head
was at you know I can see the pain in my
eyes I can see how have things changed
for you since then since this since
since that since that first
interview I've had
exponential I've had a growth of like a
spiritual growth that has been
exponential and it has shown and it
shows itself through love and it has
shown it's been shown to me through from
Love From Love like when I look at this
this for me soft white underbelly I hear
the word love Chimes over and over and
over in my head that's really what it's
all about and beauty Beauty because no
matter like you can every single one of
the photos that you've taken that I've
seen your
Stills like I don't know how you're able
to grab where this these people so well
you
know but the way like like to see myself
on the face of a
book coming from where I come from bro
like I
can't I never thought I would
um be able to be the person I am today
you know and I believe that a lot of it
comes from what I've been able to do
with you with what you've done for me
and what the people that watch this
channel have done for me people have
stopped me and been like are you Hutch
that come on [__] around fine it like
that's some come
on your dad ordered a coffee my dad
ordered a [__] C [__] yeah he did I
think half the people in my [__]
immediate family already have the [__]
on pre-order they're so happy and I'm
like wait let me ask him if I can get
one for free first man yeah I'll get you
one I love you dude I love you man thank
you so much bro this is so cool thank
you so much for putting me in this dude
I'm proud of you man I'm so glad we met
I'm proud of myself
finally that's a huge part of all of
this isn't it just you know what though
Mark being proud of yourself you know
when they interviewed you when your your
assistant interview you the other day
yeah
no
you said something you know you said
that like she said what what are some of
the interviews that get you out of bed
in the morning and you said my name bro
and how the [__] can I thank you for
that to know that there's something that
I did for another person that helps them
through their
day is the greatest honor a man can
carry other than parenting and being a
good father the best badge I can wear is
I can be like watch this interview go to
about
3:45 and listen you know because that
now it gets me out of bed in the morning
dude you know that's what gets me
through my [__] days is remembering
Mark oh yeah don't forget what Mark said
you know don't don't forget what that
dude that stopped you on the street said
or what your sister said or what your
family said or what people that at the
place that I'm at that that helps me
stay clean
said you know people don't compliment
other
people unless they are really thinking
that
you know if you think somebody's saying
you're a good person or you're beautiful
or you're kind because they want to get
something from you you're a skew they're
saying it because they believe that so
once somebody told me nah man you're
you're good you're a good guy like I
like being around you I started to
believe it and not until I was able to
believe what you said or what the people
said or or what I was actually watching
cuz some I watched it and one time first
time I didn't see myself you know
but now I see that like that's one of
the better versions of myself is this
guy pouring his [__] heart out you
know what this channel is
is I hope everybody's able to get a
piece of it at some point everybody you
know there's a lot that still
misunderstand what I'm doing but
hopefully they'll they'll figure
hopefully they'll find one of these and
say oh I get it you know because I get
it it took me a second and a lot of
people maybe they won't but I mean i'
I've done so many now I've done over
7,000 almost eight I think and uh so
often this this morning I did two where
the person said to me thank you for
listening nobody has ever heard this
nobody's ever heard me tell my story
nobody's I've never told this to anybody
and it's like I think it's important to
share these stories if we're ever going
to learn if we're ever going to learn
anything every single interview I've
watched something about every everybody
everything I've seen everybody has
something there's a bit of beauty I've
seen in every every single interview to
where the person has like an emotional
break or to where the person tells you a
story and then they they talk about how
they got over it or through it or where
they are today you know it's the the
people that are fronting are the ones
that are bragging about this [__] you
know I mean unless you're like a pimp
like [__] what's his name he's the
[__] dude like that dude's so [__]
funny he's so rad and I he's real he's
being authentic sharp what's his name
Sharp yeah that [__] dud that's who
he is bro he's like he's a character
that needs to exist you know that
there's a necessity for that man you
know and he and he you know he exploited
women and he did his thing you know what
I
mean but at the end of the day that
character is needed in our society we
need to understand his thought process
we need to understand what got him there
you know cuz people see it's like oh
it's a pimp he's a this he's that listen
to him though he's a [__] smart guy
dude he's a [__] clever cat you know
what I mean he really is and if you
listen to the people that are speaking
here so many addicts are really smart
loving good people amazing people really
good people man and they just don't get
the chance you know they they get walked
over and thank God like you didn't walk
over us bro you didn't just step over us
you stopped and you asked us what's
going on in our lives and why and you
did that dude thank you bro thank you I
love you for that I'll always love you
for that thank you yeah
bro
I